all right today's Friday and today is a
Big Show day so we're gonna be getting
ready to do that damn show tonight yeah
and the liquor prepared yeah through the
notes I got a eggplant lasagna and
they're cooking yeah we're gonna [ __ ]
ride probably about another 30 minutes
40 minutes we'll be done okay that's
good yeah cuz I had I had to bread and
baked all the and pre baked all the UH
the eggplant slices yeah yeah and I got
I got good feeling and they're going
luckily I didn't have to make sauce I
already had some frozen
I had forgotten there yeah it'll be good
I didn't know what he was up to in there
yeah do you remember that remember that
movie that we saw with Chris hams Lee we
saw it on isn't it worth Hemsworth
that's his name we saw it on Netflix it
was called extraction yeah it was like a
good action movie well we repeat it yeah
and it was like that would that be like
a tentpole movie yeah evidently that
pissed a lot of people off and damn
Hollywood because it made so much money
and it went to Netflix instead of the
theaters and I think that I think some
of these theater companies like AMC they
went out there to hire a bunch of
Twitter shells to attack it today and
over the past couple days they're
attacking that movies being racist why
today it's been out for a while they're
mad because the numbers yet I mean it's
not like it was back in a day we're
opening night you get you know opening
night in the next two or three nights it
gets a [ __ ] all of its money and it
Peters out over weeks it's not like that
on Netflix of course that shit's up
there and it's up there kind of a steak
you know or it goes to another service
after that well that thing so I can make
it all kinds of money so they hired a
bunch of damn shells to go out there and
say that that movie was racist I don't
remember anything racist about that
movie do you no no I don't live it and
they were saying that well that was that
was getting in the way of all the the
the Indian peoples normal lives and it
was brought block and traffic just
anything's like they were just called
through it to attack it for something
and I saw a [ __ ] you know what I mean
behind the scene shots a [ __ ] Chris
[ __ ] waving to the crowd and
everybody in that whole town just going
[ __ ] wild that you know that that guy
was there you know [ __ ] door
everybody knows that dude [ __ ] right
yeah man
and whoever whoever shelling and saying
this [ __ ] is pretending like like he
isn't famous worldwide you know to me
that he's an interloper
ya know he's not supposed to be over
there in those other countries and it
just shows it just shows how fake all
that [ __ ] is they're just mad because
that movie made a [ __ ] ton of money and
theater gangsters didn't get any of it
that's all it is so they just hire
people to go attack wonder though like
what I mean Netflix they're they're kind
of cagey about I'm assuming because they
are a privately private company they're
not like publicly traded so they don't
actually have to they don't actually
have to say what their revenue is or
like what their yeah income stream is so
I do wonder like do they just make money
from new releases like or new people
coming on to see the new releases or is
there some other way that they make it
because it's hard I mean I'm sure they
have some kind of determination as to
how many people streamed a particular
thing because now they have the top 10
list and [ __ ] like that and you'd have
to know like especially with TV series
that they produce like is it worthwhile
to do another yes season of this you
know if not enough people watched it or
what have you so I'm sure that that
information is something that they know
but it's just something that so it's
just something I didn't have to
publicize it but they got to show it to
somebody like the IRS cuz those [ __ ]
pay taxes well yeah I know I'm not
saying that it it's interesting to me
like where there are other revenue
streams might be coming from
well evident on the street extraction
made a [ __ ] ton of money and at least
somebody in the damn theater gangster
business believed it or knows the truth
they probably have industrial spies and
agents inside Netflix you know what I
mean
get to work so they know where the how
much you know what makes what you know
he's gonna mean that it's a scene of
course they're gonna have spies in there
evidently they didn't like what they saw
with buckin extraction it evidently made
a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] money and just
it's rumored that its production was
very efficient in terms of money you
know what I mean that was a [ __ ]
big-budget movie the helicopter [ __ ]
crash and all you know it had yes it had
it was all on location it's all on
locational practical effect almost all
practical effects that was like that
movie would back in my day
that would have been Terminator 2 it was
like that kind of a [ __ ] movie
alright and evidently its production was
pretty efficient in terms of what it
cost him to do and evidently it made a
[ __ ] ton of money and still making a
[ __ ] ton of money and then there's gonna
be blu-ray releases they'll make a lot
of money off that too you know so it's
Netflix is just kicking kicking the
living [ __ ] out of Hollywood that's
what's really happening if it wasn't
then you wouldn't see these damn chill
media on Twitter and [ __ ] you know
the the online the online [ __ ] with
like a bleeding cool and always [ __ ]
you know online magazine is evident
you'd call them online they wouldn't be
attacking it if it wasn't making a [ __ ]
ton of money
let me hired him to attack I love the
movie I thought was good it was a good
good movie like I said it was just a
throwback action movie it was a bit of
beaten benefit it would have been about
like Terminator 2 yeah back in the day
you know good writing had good
characters you know but they're saying
it was Islamophobic Man Islam was never
even [ __ ] brought up in that this is
a bunch of gangster movies and it had it
had stars from Iran and Pakistan in that
movie those cut everybody in that movie
was was a big star yeah and they got big
roles in it the kid and everything and
it was just it was just a [ __ ]
traditional action movie tail of the
same thing as Terminator 2
you got an adult male and a little kid
try to survive [ __ ] yeah that goes back
to damn old comic books with Batman and
Robin in crap that way you you're
getting the male audience the adult male
can identify with Chris Hamsi or the
villains and then kids can identify with
a little kids that's all it is
it's a it's a proven method what's that
Hemsworth [ __ ] that man that that's a
handsome [ __ ] though innit
but anyway um that's all that is that's
a tried and proven formula that formula
makes money just say yeah and then you
got this new [ __ ] Batman here I go
I'm gonna [ __ ] star Trent you got
this new Batman the new Batman I'm
writing I don't even know the dude's
name it's just the White House yet bad
guy he's naked [ __ ] so exactly he was
also in [ __ ] like the vampire that
Twilight he was still trying to get out
that's right but he's been in like good
movies since then he's really trying to
like shed that stigma oh that and that
was but Twilight would have been a good
movie I mean it made a lot of money I'm
sure he made a lot of money off of it oh
yeah
yeah no I mean they made all the money
well yeah you know the books are
terrible and the movies right the whole
purpose of these things is to make a
[ __ ] ton of money if it makes a [ __ ] ton
of money it's good far as I'm concerned
because that would be something I would
invest in it doesn't have to be artistic
you know I mean if I was to own a
restaurant would you rather own
McDonald's or would you rather own a
fine dining establishment and rather own
[ __ ] McDonald's I would rather own
[ __ ] McDonald's okay Twilight was the
McDonald's of [ __ ] entertainment you
know for a while anyway that dudes gonna
be the new Batman he don't want to work
out they hired him a trainer and
everything yeah you don't work out he
seems like a really funny they gonna sue
his ass like they're gonna sue his ass I
would imagine that if you have to well
he's probably just like why can't you
just like dude and CGI or put me in like
building yeah he don't know like I did
with the other guess what it looks like
to do that that's what it looks like
they're doing yeah cuz I don't think
Mike wasn't a Michael Keaton I don't
think he had worked out either well
that's what I mean it's like nowadays
they [ __ ] bacon CGI like
yeah [ __ ] like that so he's probably
just like why don't you just do that
yeah but what yeah dudes are taking the
easy path but the thing is though is
it's not like it was yeah it's not like
it was the dudes that go see these
superhero movies [ __ ] know what's
going on behind the scene they know
everything you know social media and
there we go like oh yeah and didn't work
out I'm not gonna sit I want to see the
real Batman he's in the [ __ ] closet
he's gonna [ __ ] cost them [ __ ]
money man I'd be suited his asses now
you're gonna not only are you gonna be
bad and I workout [ __ ] you're gonna
start taking steroids that's what I'd
tell it all though the thing about it is
that in a way it was like successful
because I got everybody talking about a
[ __ ] soy-based Batman all those dudes
in [ __ ] the Marvel Universe they
[ __ ] take steroids there's just no
other way you show the dude before
[ __ ] Marvel and this show three
months afterwards and I'm going like
yeah [ __ ] anabolic steroids we can't
get that big I've been working out for
[ __ ] two years Jenny and I get
increased in size but those dudes would
look like they [ __ ] worked out for
[ __ ] eight years you know ten years
is what they look like they worked and
he did it in three months then they're
gonna tell you I did with protein powder
creatine yeah like I said when your
contract says that you have to like look
like yeah you better [ __ ] needs and
millions of dollars at movies yesterday
we got another movie from Rob and I was
very excited about it it's sexy beast
you have not seen it I'm saying I saw it
oh I might have seen it in the theater I
said he's good but yeah I really really
like it cuz he was like oh if you liked
Bronson just like a British crime movie
and he didn't tell me what it was though
so it's like I was like oh it's like a
surprise so I opened it up and I was
like yes because I love that [ __ ]
yeah but I've already many years but
yeah we'll have to watch that and I like
how it when the label has said it came
from one of the county libraries yeah
yeah do you notice that yeah I opened it
up to see if they had taped on there the
property of the county no it was
actually printed directly on it Oh
interesting
yeah it was like part of the
labels I'm going like there might be
some collectors value with some [ __ ]
like that
now I'm kind of interested if they like
produce a set amount like to go to
libraries it must be well and you know
libraries closed out a lot in a way
they're becoming a thing of the past not
really um they have I I know a girl that
I went to high school with and she lives
in Texas I think and she the librarian
and um she's like you would be amazed at
how much [ __ ] you know how many people
come to the library still because one
you know it's not just books you can
like you can get movies you can get
music you get all for free you can do it
and get it there usually high schools
well and also they have like a bunch of
like programs and [ __ ] like that for
kids but for adults and [ __ ] too so it's
like it's really busy they have like a
lot of [ __ ] they also close down though
I've seen I've seen videos guys doing
urban explanation well you know and
libraries because whole towns close down
well yeah and then you go down in there
and they have the library I've seen some
that urbex [ __ ] videos they go into
the damn library the Xerox machine still
in there and everything all the [ __ ]
books it looks perfect they had one in
Canada that was like that yeah yeah it's
been sitting there for [ __ ] 20 years
the whole town and it's perfect yeah
nobody went in there and [ __ ] with it
it's out in the middle nowhere there's
no yeah you had to fly there it was a
mining town there and then the mine
closed down and they just left it all
pretty much in the same week yeah
sometimes they didn't take it didn't
take anything with them and there is a
road to get to it but you got to drive
like six hours without a dirt road to
get to it so there's no vandalism well
yeah because that's I mean you'd have to
be like pretty committed to vandalism
right and it was spooky man the lights
still worked it's to have power like
okay now this is like something that
always like weirds me out about a lot of
these like cuz we watch a lot of that
urban exploration and stuff and like
even some of the [ __ ] that's been like
with little big old mansions like you
know department stores like that even
stuff that's been abandoned for like a
decade or more took that power sometimes
the electricity is still like who is
paying for that like is somebody still
paying the bill or did they just not
bother turning it off because just don't
bother turning it because it wasn't
enough to yea worry about there to worry
about I guess and maybe something still
runs like water pumps or maybe something
starts to run for safety reasons or it's
it's like under in state custody in some
way yeah and so maybe like if you know
we ever need it yeah it's like for us
like for a emergency military base if we
ever needed to put people who get sick
like during a panda you know I mean
maybe they just the it was weird I mean
they go down there and they go into into
the apartment buildings and the
apartment buildings are all still fully
furnished I mean people pack their bags
and left but it's still got all the
silverware and [ __ ] and they hit the
light switch and the lights turned off
and then like they went down one hallway
this is in Canada went down one hallway
of the of the apartment complex and you
know those neon lights yeah the tube
ones they were still on and they had and
this thing had been some of them were
still off not all of them most of them
were gone out but some of them were
still on and this thing was like
abandoned in like 84 holy crap and and
everything like neon tubing code any
other lights still on let's check out
you made cuz I can't imagine I can't
imagine anybody going down there and
changing lights out yeah why would you
why would you like if no one was in
there yeah I don't really see why anyone
would bother and you know some of the
street lights were still on weird that's
crazy yeah some of them are another
weird thing too is that because you um
you showed me one where it was like it
was essentially like a mansion I don't
remember where it was but it was just
like kind of out in the middle of
nowhere and it had been abandoned I
believe in the 80s or maybe the early
90s and most of the furniture was gone
stuff like that but the weird thing was
like some of the bedrooms still had like
kids toys and clothes and stuff like
that I'm like what the [ __ ] what
happened here that like all of this
stuff is still here did everybody they
shattered oh wow
they said bankruptcy I know but it's
like you would think that if you if they
went bankrupt and had to move the the
kids would take their stuff nowhere did
they just get locked out no because
when the family moved away the kids were
already grown and gone yeah I guess
that's what it was so they just left all
just left all the stuff there because
the kids move away I know but it's just
I don't know it just seemed weird any
that you would just like leave Duchess
what and what was you know like they had
one that was a hotel slash resort and
it's here in the United States but it
had been abandoned like in the very late
70s and it's still no she's me it must
have no wasn't the 70s it was the 90s
it's the very very early 90s it was a
band but it looked like it was built in
the 70s it still had 70s decor in it but
I remember he had computers from the
early 90s that were still in it and
still worked and in the office yeah it
still had power all the rooms were made
all everything looked pristine except it
was inaccessible there was no roads to
get to it you had to walk to get to it
the roads were long gone and everything
was overgrown all the trees all the
grass was like [ __ ] way high the
trees had overgrown and once you got in
there and he didn't have a restaurant
and everything there's weird all the
exit signs were still glowing and you
could turn the lights on and it looked
pretty much perfect you could just sleep
in there if you wanted to yeah and you
know you could live in it if you wanted
to yeah I mean you should be that one
because it's just like well [ __ ] man if
you were homeless and good you can just
live in there live in there live in
there and no one would find you yeah you
could live in there like a [ __ ] King
I mean it'd be a pain in the ass if you
didn't like I said if we didn't have a
car and you had to go get groceries and
stuff there's a resort here in Florida
and Bush jr. was in it living in it or
standing at the time that 9/11 happened
and it's been abandoned and it's got all
the power and everything most of its
vandalized but it also had like a
20-story building or a couple of 20
storey buildings on the property with
like penthouses
yeah and they went up into those
penthouses and they were just like
perfect and it was where the owner lived
yeah and all of his stuff was
still in there and it had power and you
could turn the air conditioners on you
know in certain areas I think if I was
making an urban exploration video that I
found I was like well I found my new
house yeah I'm gonna stay here it was
right on a coast yeah at least till
somebody comes with the wrecking ball
yeah hopefully get some warning for that
but there are weird in the United States
at least in places in Canada there are
weird
buildings that are forgotten and haven't
had anybody in them in decades you the
owners are long dead and they're still
sitting there one of my favorite ones
that we saw was the Dan Bell one where
he went to that weird like couples
resort like yeah it was in the Poconos
yeah isn't it yeah like that one it was
it was pretty [ __ ] up but some of the
rooms like we're still in decent shape
and stuff but yeah that closed in that
must been the eighties eighties yeah I
think I think they said late 80s early
90s it just became unpopular and they
couldn't pay the bills and the owner
died and it got taken by the bank and
the bank didn't do anything with it you
know they just kind of owned the
property that it sits on and it just it
just started to crumble it looked like
something out of damn Logan's Run like
low Logan's Run [ __ ] love shop and
sexfest [ __ ] heart-shaped [ __ ]
heart shaped [ __ ] bed yeah had we
called waterfalls yeah waterfalls
everywhere and it just looked like some
kind of sleazy sleazy compact then wait
what didn't think of it as sleazy but
it's like yeah that's totally it was a
sex resort yeah for couples
yeah and and evidently it was like there
was a lot of like swapping and [ __ ]
going on in there that was like famous
for that had some key parties going yeah
it's what it was if you kids don't have
a key parties are like yeah just random
random [ __ ] take this and I'll take that
one depend on what you keys you pull out
yeah you put like all the keys in a
fishbowl when you get to the party and
whoever's whoever's keys you get that's
how you get a lake sleepeth yeah well
you went home they went home where them
yeah yeah
but that was back you know but I mean
I'm sure that really happens sometimes
but that think it was rarer than he said
but it was yeah that was that before
aids and and yeah that was the seventies
yeah that was sexual revolution and and
really you know if you [ __ ] I looked
into the fine print in in that [ __ ]
60s and 70s sexual revolution it was
mostly these leezar sleaze er suit
[ __ ] you know basically
tricking women into having sex with them
that's what most of it was everybody's
doing it baby tricking women that's why
so many people were on drugs back then
because it's like you'd have to be on
like some serious drugs to be like
sleeping with some of those dudes with
chops yeah we go pornstache yeah white
man afros yeah holy crap talking women
into doing [ __ ] they really kind of
didn't want to do yeah but then there's
once a pure pressure because the other
girls were doing it come on
and it was drugs and [ __ ] involved well
yeah I think that was probably I had a
lot to do with it their [ __ ] up they
were just like whatever yeah although
you know in our scene we [ __ ] to see
that kind of [ __ ] - yeah we know what it
is it's not to the extent that is 70s I
think got a reputation it's saying it's
different when underground [ __ ]
are doing this that know each other real
well and then mainstream people that
don't really know each other that well
that's that that was the difference
there was just people in [ __ ] clubs
and bars in bars and when Main Street
and people get ahold of [ __ ] they [ __ ]
it up well yeah I mean I think the thing
about you know the goth industrial scene
in particular is you know especially one
and the one in Orlando Tampa which is a
big city but not like a massive city so
everyone kind of knows easier than yeah
or at least knows somebody that knows
everybody you know what I mean over time
because they everybody was dating
everybody everyone's in a way kind of
[ __ ] related to one another yeah
everybody's your ex no yeah yeah not
because anybody meant for it to be like
that this is your ex everybody's like
that that is into the same [ __ ] there's
like really that many of them
everyone kind of makes the rounds yeah
all right you ready to wrap it up yeah
get the oven eat some lunch and I gotta
do some more preparation for the main
show which we're going to be recording
later on yeah so hopefully you guys have
a good rest of your Friday have a good
Friday night have a good time if you
guys are doing anything and we'll talk
to you guys again tomorrow